everyone welcome to PI data thanks for
coming out on this I see anything
risking your lives so my name is
Patricia Schuster and my profile at the
University of Michigan
Shawn law is also here who works here at
TD Ameritrade and our other Corrigan
co-organizer Ben is not here tonight we
want to start by acknowledging our
sponsors for pi data for our meetup
group numb focused sponsors the meetup
group itself TD Ameritrade provides us
this space to meet in and mitos provides
the food so if you know anyone from any
of these organizations next time you see
them say thank you a few notes
especially since we have so many new
participants today we have emergency
exits here through this door if you have
any feedback about the event please
provide it to us
through a few different ways either
Twitter and our Twitter and gmail is
here at the bottom PI day to Ann Arbor
we do put a lot of content from our
meetups on our github and the link is
right here and as a reminder we're in a
borrowed space so please clean up after
yourself so as for Q&A with the
presentation unless your questions are
quick please pull questions until the
end and try to phrase your questions in
the form of a question and keep your
questions for 30 seconds or less and
avoid like going into long statements so
we will have time for open discussion at
the end
now I want to read our code of conduct
high data is dedicated to providing a
cover a sment free meeting experience
for everyone regardless of gender sexual
orientation gender identity and
expression disability physical
appearance body size race or religion we
do not tolerate harassment of meeting of
meeting participants in any form all
communication should be appropriate for
a professional audience including people
of many different backgrounds sexual
language and imagery is not appropriate
for any of our meet-up events be kind to
others do not insult or put-down other
attendees behave professionally remember
that harassment and sexist racist or
it's
generic jokes are not appropriate for pi
data attendees violating these rules may
be asked to leave the meetup at the sole
discretion of the meetup organizers
thank you all for helping make this a
welcoming and friendly event now we want
to do a quick icebreaker so you can meet
some of the other people here so please
turn to somebody you don't know and
introduce yourself and then in 15
seconds
please reflect on the title of the talk
today privacy is not dead and tell them
whether you agree with that statement
I was like how much what you guys talk
to me
yeah
so what you think though your question
the name of that
I think
[Music]
this month in data science there's an AI
company called deep mind that
participated in a protein folding
competition and they built a model
called alpha fold and it actually beat
out the prominent scientists in the
field and predicting protein folding so
this is a big application of AI to an
academic field pretty interesting
especially for us academics I also want
to prove up promote the next event next
month MIDI can mark she is a very famous
in the nuclear engineering world and her
talk will be on widgets jupiter widgets
for volumetric data explorations she's
from the university of illinois so
that'll be March 13th also want to
mention an event coming up from our
friends at a 2d plern they are hosting
their event later in the month and it's
free but you need to sign up in advance
and it's hosted with the University of
Michigan so it's on North Campus
are there any community announcement so
now's your time to share anything that
you want to share with the group maybe
if you have a job opening or if you're
looking for a job
and in the back
and your name key yes okay so if you're
looking for people talk to keen
terms of legal expertise
great in your name Sam excellent
did I see one more hand Brian Brian work
at interactive we have an open record
it's a plot of um Python deep learning
excellent
but more Anusha
excellent all right all right so now we
will start the talk on our speaker today
is Helen Odom she works here at TVA as
senior legal counsel where she helps the
business work through complex legal
issues at the intersection of technology
media brand and innovation and her talk
will be called privacy is not dead so
let's welcome our speaker well thank you
for having me today sounds like this is
gonna be a slightly different topic from
what you used to hearing about I didn't
even know what those words meant for
next month's speaker so that's sounds
pretty cool right
excellent so the topic today is privacy
isn't dead and I guess it's kind of
intentionally unintentionally
provocative right I wanted to make sure
got some people's attention really does
privacy law get people really excited
but hopefully this Elise gets your
attention and I wanted to talk about
this because I do think as we saw from a
show of hands earlier right there is
this idea out there that people don't
care about privacy that it doesn't
matter that it's dead or it's dying and
I believe from one that that's not true
and that probably privacy matters more
today than it ever has in the history of
humanity and especially privacy is a
legal right and a legal concept and
that's we're going to talk about today
and when you especially when you look at
the activities of law makers and
regulators and even this is one of many
similar statistics that the vast
majority of at least US consumers are in
favor of passing a national data privacy
law right so this shows that people
actually do care they're concerned about
how their data is being used what's
happening with it and they want some
more controls in place what are we going
to talk about so the intersection of
data and the law is a really big really
big topic we're going to be covering
what is privacy exactly exactly what do
we mean by that we're going to cover the
history of privacy and kind the
evolution of very high-level history of
the evolution of privacy laws and then
we're going to apply the principles that
we learn about to the Internet of Things
more specifically so we'll have a kind
of fun
law school exam moment for us at the
back half we're not going to be covering
data breach we're not going to be
covering data security we're not going
to be covering international privacy
laws and any real depth and I'm not
going to be talking about company or
industrial data as the name suggests
privacy really talks about personal
information personal data although with
Internet of Things there's actually a
really kind of interesting convergence
now between personal information and
industrial data which we'll talk about a
little bit towards the end okay so let's
start what is privacy uh well I think a
lot of people think that privacy has to
do with solitude in seclusion
the idea of kind of the hermit going off
in the woods alone you know one reason
for this beautiful image here but that's
not exactly right right because solitude
is actually about not being around other
people you're physically not present
with other people but you can be present
with other people and still be private
still have privacy another idea about
privacy is that has to do a secrecy
right or hiding information and we kind
of get this sense that only bad people
need privacy right only criminals are
people who have something to hide
actually need or want privacy but that's
also very much not true right I mean we
if somebody were to out you was gay or
as pregnant we would have a problem with
that that's not okay and I think
especially that idea that privacy is
about secrecy can potentially become
very dangerous when it's used to justify
invasions of privacy such as we see with
mass surveillance programs it's a very
slippery slope when you start thinking
that way so if it's not about solitude
and it's not about secrecy what is it
privacy the legal sense of privacy is
the control that we have over
information about ourselves okay so it's
the right to control information that we
have about ourselves and the reason why
privacy exists as a right or why it's
has been identified as a right we're
going to go into that a little bit but
privacy really gets to the fundamental
ass
six of our humanity right it gets to our
ability to identify ourselves to control
our identity self-determination to
determine who we enter into
relationships with so privacy is really
as it's one of those things is that the
root of just our very human nature and
that's one of the reasons why it's
actually been recognized in the
Universal Declaration of Human Rights as
a fundamental human right because it is
so essential to our humanity and I
thought I turned off slack but
apparently it still works sorry about
that so let's start with the history of
privacy then where did this idea come
from because it's actually somewhat of a
modern legal concept most legal scholars
trace the history of privacy back to a
lower the article that was published in
a Harvard Law Review in 1890 and it was
called the right to privacy does
aptly-named
and the history of this article is kind
of the stuff of legal legend he was the
late 19th century and it was the era of
yellow journalism and Samuel Warren one
of the co-authors his family was part of
Boston social elite he had married the
daughter of a senator and their personal
lives were just covered in
excruciatingly an embarrassing detail by
the press at the time just hounded by
the paparazzi basically and I guess
there was an incident at his daughter's
wedding and it just kind of put him over
the edge and he turned to his law
partner and law school classmate Louis
Brandeis who lucky for him went on to
become Supreme Court justice so what
kind of brilliant legal mind and they
put their heads together and they
basically invented this right to privacy
they wrote this article where they made
the argument that this right existed and
what they did was they went back and
they surveyed hundreds of cases all the
way back to English common law and they
looked for cases that had issues that
were kind of similar to what the warren
family was experiencing and they looked
in how those cases were being decided
and saw that they were being decided on
just all sorts of legal grounds property
contract intellectual property
defamation different torts so just
really all over the map
but what they identified was that what
was
really going on was the courts were
actually recognizing that there is a
different legal right here that is not
addressed by these other regimes by
these other doctrines and that other
right was or that other issue was the
unconsented publication of true facts so
you know in a defamation case for
example if someone were to publish
something about me that's not true that
would be a claim for defamation because
it's not true but if you publish
something about me that's true
for example maybe I'm gay or I'm
pregnant or whatever that's not
defamation because it's true but they're
still wrong they're right that we needs
to be addressed and so they identify
basically this unmet need and the legal
doctrine at the time and said that's
really what the courts are doing here
and they termed that the right to
privacy and they said the time has come
basically that this right should be
acknowledged for what it is and it
should be given teeth and you know
should be enforceable and and that's you
know that's how this whole idea of the
right to privacy got started they define
the right to privacy in the article is
the right of determining to what extent
one's thoughts sentiments and emotions
shall be communicated to others so
against that the the idea is that it's
the right to choose and to control the
information about yourself now in the
hundred or so years after the
publication of this article we've seen
obviously a very dramatic evolution of
this right to privacy I would say the
first few decades there was not even a
lot of agreement about whether they got
it right and whether this right actually
did exist or if it should exist the
court slowly started catching on and
kind of experimenting and issuing cases
that were decided under this right to
privacy but wildly inconsistent
decisions just all over the map
no agreement about what this right
actually was or how it should be applied
in a legal context and actually a
William Prosser who authored the restate
'men of torts in 1860 identified that by
that time there were at least four
separate different tort claims that were
all being asserted all under the name
right to privacy but they were actually
completely different issues and
completely different wrongs so there's
just a lot of confusion at the
what is this right and how should it be
applied but also at the time you see a
lot of development in technology and by
the 1970s the government is now at this
point using computers in computer
databases to process records about
citizens and this was starting to raise
a whole host of concerns from the public
about you know about their privacy and
about potential abuses and in response
to those concerns the Secretary of
Education put together the special
advisory committee to look into these
issues with the use of automated data
processing systems to process the the
records of citizens in particular they
were looking at like Social Security
numbers and what was happening with
Social Security numbers at the time and
they were supposed to come up with some
recommendations and guidelines to
protect civil liberties and they did
that and the result was this report
published in 1973 called records
computers and the rights of citizens and
the guidelines that they put forth was
this code of Fair Information practice
and it sees five simple principles that
eventually became codified into law the
following year the Privacy Act was
issued which still is in place today and
governs all federal agencies and how
they process data
so this reports still very relevant the
code of Fair Information practice
eventually evolved into something a
little more general a little more
general framework that we now call the
Fair Information practice principles and
these principles are articulated
slightly differently kind of depending
on where you look but it all kind of
oils down to these five basic principles
and this particular articulation I
pulled from the Federal Trade Commission
Act I'm sorry the Federal Trade
Commission's reports to Congress in 1998
on online privacy but the principles are
as follows the first is notice and
awareness and this is as the name
suggests the idea that consumers should
be made aware of how their information
is being collected and used before it's
actually collected and used the second
and closely related principle is choice
and consent and this is the idea that
consumers should have an option
about how their data is going to be used
in particular secondary uses the third
principle is access or participation and
this is the idea that consumers should
be able to access what information
companies have about them and this is
going to be really familiar familiar to
us for example with the credit reports
right everybody gets to get one free
credit report from each of the credit
reporting agencies every year and that's
you know because of this principle the
fourth principle is integrity and
security and this gets to the idea that
the information we have about consumers
should be accurate right it would be bad
if somebody said you know I'm an 85 year
old male and actually you know a woman
in my 30s that would be inaccurate and
bad and it should be secure which means
obviously that it should be secured from
unauthorized disclosure the last
principle is enforcement or redress
which simply means that these principles
have to have teeth right people have to
be able to enforce them there has to be
some kind of a stick that's going to get
companies to comply with these
principles and the FIPS essentially form
the basis for every single privacy law
around the world today this notice and
choice model that they you know that
they propose is is basically them all
around the world and this is just a
snapshot of privacy laws now I will say
I pulled this in December it's a little
bit out of date because Brazil and 2018
passed their first data privacy law it
doesn't go into effect until next year
though which is probably why it's not up
on the map but you can see that you know
data privacy laws are just they're
proliferating around the world and 2018
was actually a particularly active year
I would say for privacy legislation it
was the year that the general data
protection regulation in Europe went
into effect which was the just a huge
overhaul of their Data Protection
Directive the first and decades
extremely onerous compliance conditions
extremely harsh penalties if you get it
wrong right up to 4% of your global
annual turnover if you get it wrong so
that's a big deal of here you know a
Google or Facebook
also in the United States 2018 was a big
year
the most notable update of 2018 to the
US with the passage of the California
consumer Privacy Act which is considered
the first GDP are like legislation in
the United States California has always
been kind of at the forefront and
privacy legislation they were the first
state to pass a law that actually
required a privacy policy being posted
online and they just have always kind of
been on the cutting edge of privacy
issues but they passed in record time I
think two days this legislation in order
to avoid it becoming a constitutional
ballot initiative so because it was
passed so quickly there actually a
number of errors and ambiguities and
inconsistencies that they're trying to
figure out incorrect before it goes into
effect next year but you see here I just
have a snapshot from the preamble of
this law the intention of the California
Legislature right and what they're
trying to do with this new big omnibus
privacy law and the principles here
basically are again the FIPS in action
rights these same principles that
they're trying to protect we're going to
talk more about the CCPA in our in our
hypothetical in a bit but I will just
again echo that it is very broad and
even though it's a California law it
will apply to any company that collects
personal information from 50,000 or more
people households or devices that are in
California so yes sir
information practices
um ostensibly but you know there are
other laws that come into play with with
the NSA and I mean that's just the first
of many this is not a by all like by any
account a survey of every single privacy
law in the United States that would take
you know here's to go through that in
detail right right no understood yeah so
back to California though thank you for
the question again this law is intended
to be broad and have broad application
just like the GDP are and collection
under this law is both active and
passive so that would apply to for
example cookies collecting IP addresses
through cookies now is specifically
covered under the CCPA a little bit of
ambiguity before if that was actually
considered personal information well if
for sure is on there CCPA all right so
this brings us to our fun law school
exam hypothetical the Internet of Things
and what I found really interesting is I
went back and was looking back through
the history of privacy laws is there
really is a strong correlation I know I
shouldn't use that word with this
particular group of people but the
correlation between technology and the
evolution of technology and privacy laws
Warren and Brandeis talked in their
article about new photographic
technologies that can you know record
people in their homes and there were
articles in the 60s that we're talking
about basically wearables that collected
biometric information and geolocation
tracking and you know devices that could
record your conversations without even
knowing it and then in the 90s when you
start just seeing law after law being
passed you have the internet you have
faxes and text messaging and now BOTS
and just you know the more technology
evolves the more complex it gets and the
more integrated it becomes with our
everyday life and our personhood our
actual you know physical being the more
laws we start seeing to be passed right
so now that we are in this fourth
Industrial Revolution where any device
pretty much anything in the world
physical world can be collected can be
connected and start collecting day
an entirely new kinds of data that we're
just unimaginable you know 10 15 20
years ago what how are these laws gonna
evolve and how are they going to be
applied now you know in this new context
so this is the basis for our fun
hypothetical and we're gonna think
specifically about connected doorbells
and these exist today right you can buy
them video doorbells this particular
device comes from a patent application
that recently published owned by Amazon
I believe it's part of the ring line of
doorbells that Amazon purchased but the
patent is owned by Amazon and
essentially what this patent claims is a
method to create a composite facial
image from multiple partial facial
images so that way you can more
accurately you know identify who it is
at your door I guess the problem is that
if you have a camera that only looks
this way and you're kind of standing
here you can't get it you don't really
know who it is so they have this fancy
you know device that's inside of the
lens to be able to capture multiple
partial images and then they put it all
together to get a create a composite
facial image and then on top of that the
patent talks about potentially adding
metadata so for example maybe they add
data from the sex offender registry list
right so to help you identify is this
person a sex offender and are they then
suspicious and should I notify the
police or they talk about maybe adding
logo information right so they can pick
up if you're you know UPS delivery
driver or something you will maybe
identify that in the image and tell the
homeowner other kind of behavioral
characteristics that patent talks about
so it's a video camera they talk about
collecting for example you know motion
imagery to determine are they crouching
or are they
loitering for unnecessarily long periods
of time right different behaviors that
may indicate this is a suspicious person
and then the patent talks about you know
in creating this facial image overlaying
this metadata and setting it to the
homeowner to be able to make an
evaluation of is this a suspicious
person or an authorized person and they
can then
that information or that image also with
their neighbors so right now has a
neighborhood watch app which is
basically a virtual version of your good
old fashioned neighborhood watch and so
people can help each other out and say
oh no I know that guy he's you know my
cousin or whatever right he's fine and
you can also automatically send it to
the police
in which case and the police would be
able to make their own determination
about whether they need to take action
on this person so that is our technology
that we're going to talk about this
connected doorbell and obviously the
benefits our home security and safety
and crime reduction I mean ring Bose on
their website that their doorbells have
helped to reduce home burglary crimes by
up to 50% in certain neighborhoods so
potentially very significant benefits to
using this technology but let's have a
little bit of audience participation so
what kinds of personal information could
this type of device potentially
theoretically collect yes I have we're
gonna get there but let's yeah let's
stick with what kind of personal
information could it collect sorry was
it fingerprints yes sure you got to
touch the doorbell right so scan your
fingerprint yep did you raise your hand
sure yep your image geolocation sure yep
yeah absolutely yep yeah it does talk
about that you know scanning retina iris
kind of other biometrics yep absolutely
yep my can of collect audio it's doing
video yep yep yep anything else come to
mind yes sure
right okay so that may not be personal
information but I like where you're at
and we'll actually talk about that
towards again the conversation yes
right
right right so you're thinking more like
the owner the homeowners information for
sure yeah I mean you've got to share
your information with the company most
thing that's where the device itself
right if you come up to the door that's
part of my hypothetical we'll get there
yeah yes sir for sure yeah
why couldn't and pick up that absolutely
everybody's got their phone on them
right maybe it connects to it yeah so
these are all really great examples and
I think if we kind of kept thinking you
just go deeper deeper into this and see
that this technology is potentially very
powerful and I you know I kind of like
the idea what if you connect it to like
a connected door handle right so you
have not only the doorbell but the door
handle now I potentially got a palm
print I potentially got you know my body
temperature or my heart rate or you know
blood alcohol levels I mean who knows
right what could be picked up by this
technology and that's kind of the point
so all of what we just talked about
would be considered personal information
under the CCPA without a doubt the CCPA
is very broad it relates to any
information that identifies relates to
describes it's capable of being
associated with or could reasonably be
linked directly or indirectly with a
particular consumer or household and it
of course all the usual suspects social
driver's license name etc it also covers
online identifiers so maybe your Twitter
handle etc IP addresses your purchasing
or consuming histories or tendencies
internet or other electronic network
activity information including your
browsing history search history and
information regarding a consumers
interaction with a website application
or advertisement so all those fun little
marketing you know Oba type activities
are now very clearly covered under CCP a
geolocation data audio electronic visual
thermal olfactory or similar information
so I guess that this device could
somehow pick up your scent and record it
your scent would be covered and then a
whole host of biometric information
which we covered like I
retina fingerprint face hand palm vein
patterns voice recordings keystroke
patterns rhythms gait patterns rhythms
sleep health or exercise data so just a
huge broad variety of information that
is now covered by the CCPA and a lot of
that could be picked up by a connected
doorbell one thing that's important to
note is that the seat the definition of
personal information under the CCPA does
not include publicly available
information but publicly information is
not publicly available just because
you're in public and I observe you doing
it okay so that is actually specifically
not publicly available information under
the Act
so the fact you know that you may be
walking by in public on a public street
if I pick up that activity on this
camera that doesn't somehow make what
you're doing publicly available right it
also specifically says that repurposing
government records or data in a way that
is not compatible with the original
purpose is not considered publicly
available information right so it kind
of makes me think about that sex
offender registry list right or the
FBI's 10 most wanted
are they repurposing that information in
a way that's not the original intent
so is that actually publicly available
information for them to use I will also
say there are a number of three
specifically biometric information
protection acts in the United States
Illinois has the most punitive of all of
them but all of this information would
also be considered biometric information
under that act and we'll talk about the
Illinois act a little bit more here so
let's talk it let's apply the principles
then to this technology the first notice
and awareness so obviously under CCP a
and the Illinois Act both of them
require providing notice to consumers
before you collect information about
them the Illinois Act actually requires
you provide written notice before you
collect information from them so how is
it doorbell going to provide written
notice to consumer before it collects
this information about them and it's not
just the homeowner it's anyone whose
data is being captured very good
question I don't
we have an answer to that second
principle is choice and consent as we
know the consumer has to say yes you
know has to consent to that and the
Illinois law actually requires that you
obtain express written consent from the
consumer to collect and use their data
so again how are you gonna get express
written consent from the you know the
delivery guy who's just going up to the
door to collect this information and to
process it access and participation our
third principle so here right this would
require ring to the the CCPA would
require them to basically provide their
file on you if you ask them they have to
provide it within 45 days given the
amount of information that ring is
probably collecting and the fact that
the homeowner can go on and add their
own information right they can say oh I
know you your name is X or you know
identify their relationship to you ring
probably knows exactly who you are
specifically I don't know that this
information is being anonymized during
you know to suit Onam eyes in any way it
would kind of make it a useless product
if the whole point is to specifically
identify people and be able to recall
that information so if they get a
request you know under this act though
they'll probably have to comply with it
be interesting to see how that
compliance requirement plays out once
the law goes into effect integrity and
security I mean how do you secure a
doorbell right all these laws require a
reasonable security and security that's
appropriate to the nature of the device
and the information being collected
there is no bright line there's no clear
standard about what would be considered
reasonable security of a connected
doorbell I would say as well that
California also in 2018 passed the first
of its kind Internet of Things security
law so also you know specifically
requiring connected devices to be
secured so now you know we have multiple
laws on the books that specifically
require a doorbell to be secured but
again the practical how do you do that
you know no no no good guidance on that
right now and the last principle
enforcement or redress these statutes
are for real I mean they have teeth all
of them can be enforced by regulators
both the CCPA and the Illinois law can
be enforced by private citizens and they
have statutory damages and potential for
class-action claims so you think about
the amount of day of this being
collected the number of consumers about
whom data's been collected and very
potentially serious class-action claims
could be raised here if they're not
complying with with these laws so that's
a very interesting question I'm glad you
asked me he asked if you can file a
claim if you don't have an injury and
that was actually my next point was that
just in the last two weeks out of
Illinois the Illinois Supreme Court
answered that question under least the
Illinois statute and they said that you
do not need to prove any kind of
financial or you know physical personal
harm that a violation of the Act was
sufficient to have standing because this
addresses a human right and so that
pretty much answers that question at
least in Illinois at least for the
Illinois statute right I think there's
still some ambiguity around that it's a
federal level and other states may reach
a different conclusion but at least you
know in Illinois which as we know is is
a very serious issue and has really hard
compliance requirements and real teeth
to it real penalties that's at least
going to open the door to a lot of class
action litigation in Illinois
okay so that's our law school exam you
all passed congratulations now there are
a couple of related concepts that I do
want to touch on they're not directly in
the fifths but they are very important
in emerging issues and I think this is
getting to some of the questions that we
talked about earlier
the CCPA has this kind of fifth
principle that they recognize that's not
overtly recognizing the fifths right now
but maybe would be added to them in the
future and it says principle of
anti-discrimination the idea that
businesses should not be allowed to
discriminate against consumers who
exercise their privacy rights or based
on their privacy choices now there are I
mean the the CCPA does provide for
certain business models right where that
would be appropriate and you can offer
different levels of goods or services
based on the information you collect
right so you want to personalize your
services etc that still is okay but if
somebody says I want you to delete all
your data about me you can't then you
know penalize them by providing of a
completely different level of service or
at a different price but I think this
kind of begs a question of what if the
technology itself discriminates right
and this is I think we've seen a lot of
press about this in particular with this
ring product and facial recognition
technology this is becoming increasingly
hot topic for lawmakers and just in you
know in in the public and the ACLU in
particular when this patent application
published publish an article about it
because they see it as connecting ring
with recognition which is Amazon's
Amazon Web service AI facial recognition
technology and they the ACLU had
previously done a report on recognition
which showed that basically it was not
all that accurate at the end of the day
it in correctly matched 28 members of
Congress identifying them as people who
had been arrested for a crime and
unfortunately the technology of these 20
people who had been falsely matched
about 38% of them were people of color
so this lines up with previous reached
research that shows that facial
recognition technology is less accurate
people with darker skin tones and for
women so we kind of have an issue here
right and this gets to the idea of
ethics you know technology ethics and
data ethics and these potential
unintended consequences of using this
technology you know very good intentions
you want to secure your home you want to
secure your neighborhood but very real
potential for very serious unintended
consequences here especially when you
think about as the patent claims if that
goes directly to the police right and
now you're you're not even doing
anything there's actually not been a
crime committed at all but someone
randomly has flagged you as suspicious
whatever that means
and now you're going right to the police
right I mean it just it's it doesn't
stretch the imagination to see the
potential negative consequences of that
and I would say that you know Amazon
employees shareholders of Amazon civil
rights organizations beside you know in
addition to the ACLU and even Congress
have now written to Amazon and Jeff
Bezos personally and asked him to stop
offering recognition to law enforcement
they want them to pull back on this
technology until they can think through
some of these issues and until some
controls can be put into place so the
issue of unintended consequences from
the collection of data and especially
the potential for discrimination is very
real and I think something that we're
going to continue to see a lot of you
know a lot of attention to by the
legislators and by by the public in
different civil rights groups in the
future and the ugly truth here is a
reference to I don't know if you
remember the revelation about a facebook
employee from a couple years ago who
wrote this internal memo where he talked
about basically their growth at all cost
mentality you know and even if someone
dies because of a terrorist attack right
that happened because of Facebook you
know connecting people they still
connect people they believe in it's so
deeply that even if people get harmed
you know they're gonna continue to do
what they do and so you know it's kind
of applying that mentality here all
right so the last topic that I want to
cover which is again not directly
related to the fifth but really in
is the question of who actually then
owns the data so in our in our
hypothetical here you know the device
itself is manufactured by ring and
they're obviously going to collect a
number a bunch of information and have
it on their servers and they would also
want to have information on the devices
themselves right are they performing
well what's the ambient weather you know
so they can continue to improve their
product in our little hypothetical we
had the postal delivery man you know at
the door what about potential trade
secret information I am you know that
ring is now inadvertently collecting to
your point right
they now have some employee data maybe
they have trade or delivery route
information right what are what are the
USPS you know the postal services rights
in this scenario and then of course he
of the individual who has all of this
information about them being collected
what what are their rights at this point
in this information the ring has right I
mean if ring is going to go off and
monetize it in all these ways do they
get a cut of that do they get some
benefit of that who actually owns data
and I will tell you the law doesn't
answer that question really today I
think we tried to apply other legal
frameworks like intellectual property or
their frameworks to it but it's very
very unclear and I'm not sure that IP
I'm actually a sort of IP attorney by
trade mostly that IP really actually use
the right framework for this I think
even there's a question of is data even
intangible or is it tangible right I
mean there's some emerging kind of
physics out there that shows that data
actually has tangible qualities and that
changes the way that that the law thinks
about it and write and what doctrines
may apply the closest law that we or the
closest case kind of that we have on
this I think to date is a US Supreme
Court case that dealt with the phone
book and copyright in the phone book and
so that that case one phone book was
basically suing the manufacturer of
another phone book and saying you know
you guys copied our our phone book
records and you know you shouldn't be
allowed to do that
and the court held that while you know
the layout and kind of compilation and
everything is potentially copyrightable
something that couldn't be opened as
proprietary the data in it right the
personal information people's names or
phone numbers their address
it's just facts it's data you can't own
that so that's not copyrightable and the
court the supreme court had this really
kind of interesting analogy they said
that that that information existed
before the phone book did anything with
it and it would continue exist even if
the phone book did not exist so the data
was basically discovered right and they
kind of draw this interesting analogy to
this distinction between discovery and
invention for example or discovery and
creation right and we kind of firmly
over this from a patent context and the
idea that laws of nature things that
naturally occur in nature you can't
pound that you can't own it you can't
patent gravity and own it you can
discover it but it's kind of there for
everyone to use it's just it exists so I
think it's a really interesting analogy
that they used in the copyright case and
it kind of I don't know for me it makes
me think so how does that apply then for
personal information today right if data
is just out there right I mean and it
just exists then can anyone really own
it should anyone own it but I think
these are all very important questions
that will need to be answered especially
as our data economy continues to evolve
and data monetization continues to
become an extremely important data
business model right I mean the question
of who owns data and then what rights do
they have in that matter it matters for
you know securing financing and for you
know being able to engage in all sorts
of commercial transactions so that's the
end of my talk I think I actually have
some time left over to answer questions
if they're already
[Applause]
yeah so I mentioned that Oracle earlier
I think was about bringing recognition
I even ready yet Sam I love to do okay
Wow which article are you thinking about
they're human they're people have
effectively paid to install a right well
that's kind of the ACLU is concern right
is that effectively what you have is a
massive decentralized privately owned
surveillance system that the government
has a backdoor into right so that's kind
of underlying the ACL u--'s concerns
with it I thought what I thought you
were talking about was an article I
think just from the last couple of days
the San Francisco has now introduced
legislation to actually ban the use of
facial recognition technology by their
city agencies so wouldn't ban personal
use I believe but at least used by the
police and other city agencies
the litigation right right well yes
absolutely so the the question was about
whether I guess the litigation is really
going to be an effective you know
enforcement mechanism I think now that
the door has been open with the Illinois
decision of the last couple weeks right
that you do actually have standing to
have a case just by a violation a
compliance violation that is a very real
threat right because that was basically
the argument before if a company got
sued they said well they weren't
actually harmed right there wasn't any
harm here that it was any money
they weren't harmed you know there was
nothing happens and and that's a
requirement to bring a lawsuit is that
you have to be able to show harm so this
is actually a very important issue
because if they don't have standing then
you can't even proceed with a lawsuit so
at least in this Illinois statute right
it's very clear if you have just a
procedural compliance violation that's a
harm and it'll be interesting to see you
know how other courts react and the
legislators and the regulators but if
that ends up being kind of the direction
that this goes then yeah
companies are in for a world of pain
because you combine that with
class-action litigation and the
potential for statutory damages which
can get up into the thousands per
violation right so this is per violation
this is per person who has been harmed
you think about the number of data
breaches that have happened lately
right it's a similar issue and data
breach legislation this is why those
damages can get to meet the hundreds and
millions of dollars
um that would have to depend on what
happens with some of the federal the
pending federal laws right so there are
there increasingly calls to actually
pass a federal privacy law because of
our complex patchwork that we have now
between federal and state and you know
overlapping rights so if that law were
to say that it preempts all other
privacy laws in the country then maybe
right but I don't know if it would have
that level of preemption right yes sir
yeah he asked are you talking about
California okay the question was whether
privacy laws generally differentiate
between data and derivative data right I
would say it depends I'll give you a
little answer right it depends on the
law right and some of them have
distinctions between like anonymized and
Sudama is data but they're they're
inconsistent yes sir
police having access to Sunday prices
we don't have free access to the camera
the way the technology works and like as
the patent describes is that the
homeowner would be able to choose
whether they send that to the police
it's basically a way to give the police
a call right and say this is happening I
need you to come check it out right I
would say that's true in the case of
ring now recognition is different again
recognition is an AWS facial recognition
AI technology right and they actually do
have partnerships with local police
departments for the police to be able to
upload basically their photo databases
and/or photographs from crime scenes or
things like that and to be able to use
then recognition to help identify
criminals or people of interest I mean
they're using it in different ways right
but they do have police departments are
actively using recognition right I mean
that's so that's a good question the
question was basically the distinction
between public and private right and
observing behavior in a public space
we're recording in a public space and
whether that's public or private I mean
I think that's exactly the kind of
ambiguity that this new law raises that
needs to be answered
didn't get sued because it was available
so some of the stuff that you're
mentioning sounds like they're treading
on that recording of something in public
is bad but people just listening in to a
conversation is right we'll keep in mind
that the Act really applies to
businesses and corporate use of data in
corporate collection and use and there
are some protections and carve-outs for
like First Amendment purposes or First
Amendment protections right but I think
that the the point here is that you know
if as a company you can't just go and
observe people on the streets and
consider that to not be personal
information just because they're in
public right under this a new law that
was my interpretation of it is that that
is considered personal information Stone
because it relates to a person at the
end of the day are you the question is
is there a difference between collecting
people about a person versus just people
in general what do you mean by people in
general
right so I mean it's it's the definition
of personal information remember is
anything that's even capable of being
identified with a particular person so I
think you'd have to really I'm not sure
how you could collect all of that and
not be able to tie it back to a
particular person but again that's a
great question right how is this going
to apply to research activities because
companies engage in research to write I
mean legitimate research how was in a
how are those kind of situations going
to play out on it is law to be seen they
would treat each subset of users from
different states data differently and
how how much confidence do they have to
know about users like home state yeah
that's it I mean this when you start
talking about especially
multi-jurisdictional or international
compliance this gets very complex right
because now you have to think about
multiple countries privacy laws of
regulations and how can you comply with
all of them and in some cases yeah the
apps will basically have different
versions for different people different
come in different countries and
different privacy policies different
disclosures different data collection
practices right they some countries even
have data localization requirements
right so you maybe you have to actually
keep the data in a server that's located
in a country you can't even have it
cross borders right I mean it's gets
extremely complicated very fast
is it generally like her California
one--this California have their own
regulatory body that like check for some
of these you get to almost go into their
data center right right absolutely so
California does its the Attorney General
right at California is primarily the one
that would be be bringing these these
actions but each state has its own
Attorney General right and then you have
federal regulators as well so and then
you know of course other countries have
their own enforcement and redress
mechanisms hopefully this talk today
that he'll engage provides a different
perspective of when we're doing that
data how important it is to keep in mind
privacy the law right so with that lets
thank uh Helen together